What's up guys!
We are Pongfinity
We are back with another episode of Street Battles.
We have 5 battles with 5 different items.
If they manage to beat us, they can keep the item.
Let's see how it goes!
Which item shall I play with?
Let's go with the American football.
Alright, the American football is tempting.
Okay, let's battle it out!
This is going to be difficult!
Slightly too far!
No chance, 4-0!
I feel that I'm playing well
But you are simply too good!
The first mistake!
Comeback time!
I would need to start scoring more points if I still want to win!
Andre Agassi style
I let you make the mistakes
It seems to be working well!
You are playing really smart, no mistakes!
Very well played!
Here is your prize!
Thank you!
You lost the best playing item now.
Yeah!
Beginner's luck!
No... that was a skillful performance!
Let's take the nerf gun
That's a great prize.
Alright, let's go with this!
I have to figure out how to play with this.
I'll start serving
I started with my best serve
And that was my worst serve!
Have to even it out a bit
What part did that hit?
1-3
1-4
This is not looking good
What do we play to?
To 11 points
This isn't working at all!
I'll have to try out another strategy.
I'll try this.
That worked!
Almost.
It went all over the place with this one!
11-2.
That was it! Thanks.
Here you go, a great toy for you.
Oh nice, this is great!
Good luck with the next games!
Two points. Two points!
I got humiliated!
We have to start winning matches guys!
So, three items left.
What shall we choose?
Something hard, the meat hammer!
Alright, let's go with the meat hammer!
I'll start
4-1.
You went for the hard shot!
Wasn't too far!
Okay, I'll have to start playing better
Ah, can't miss that one!
Off the net!
I did this in the army a lot.
Just put the ball on the table and nobody had a chance.
10-9.
Congratulations, well played!
Here's your prize.
Lovely!
Can make some burgers for my girlfriend!
Sounds good!
Now we have lost three in a row...
Alright guys, so I have to win at least one of these two remaining matches.
And if you haven't subscribed yet, remember to  do it right here!
Which one do you choose?
This is a sure thing: the teddy bear!
Okay, the teddy bear!
Haven't tried playing with this before, we'll see how it goes.
Let's try it out!
Strong start
It goes easily over
Bad touch
Here we go, 5-4.
Off the net and over!
I'll try the last points with the tummy.
Match point.
Thank you!
Another loss for us!
You won a teddy bear!
That will go to good use!
Great!
No can do, this just isn't working for us!
This is what we have left
So, you get a mini fan if you beat me.
Alright, it's good for the Summer!
That wasn't directly a promising start.
Good save!
No, the wind didn't help me
Wrong way!
That would have been good!
I thought that I got that one too!
10-5, match point!
And now it starts...
10-6.
10-7.
No way!
I need to play well now!
That was intense!
Thank you!
That was a tight match!
First win of the day!
Yeah, our first win!
But that was such a good game that we will give you the fan!
Something to keep you cool during the Summer!
It was a fun match, thanks again!
Good match!
Okay, so that proved to be a lot more difficult than we thought.
Yeah, the items were way harder than in our previous street battles.
Yeah, and the opponents were really good!
Leave a comment where you want us to make the next street battle!
And watch our previous episodes there!
Until next time!